Speaker 1: It is that time of the week time for
the mailbag. Every day we get hundreds of emails
and we feature around 10 of them a week on
the Friday show. If you have something to say,
you can email info at David Pakman. Dot com
will occasionally feature a Twitter reply or
a Facebook post or whatever, really, but info
at David Pakman dot com is the place to email.
Let's start with something ugly will build to
the good messages, but we're going to start with
something ugly. This is someone named L.A. Mob
Squad who wrote to me about the subject You
and your senile diaper wearing poultice will
forever be to blame for the collapse of the
U.S. and our standing on the world stage. This is
very weaponised. I'm warning you. L.A. Mob Squad
writes, I hope you realize these four years will
be looked back at historically as a humiliating,
disastrous period in USA history directly caused
by delusional loons like you who make up the
Democratic Party. Remember, I'm not a Democrat. I
don't care about the Democratic Party. You can say
completely ridiculous and illogical B.S. all you
want. But we both know we're way past the point
where you can deflect blame and pretend that
the USA, the West's drastic decline fall on the
world stage of this magnitude is falling on the
shoulder of anybody other than senile Joe Biden.
Wait. Gas prices are up everywhere, it's not just
Joe Biden. Many countries are figuring out what to
do about Russia and Ukraine, not just Joe Biden.
I don't even know what he's talking about going on
to say there's no way you or anybody else can make
a case to the contrary while sounding even a tiny
bit reasonable. Nope, we're way past that. This
U.S. collapse will forever be on your shoulders,
and it's effing hilarious in a super disappointing
kind of way. You talk about Trump and then bring a
guy in and you make us look like an effing weak,
crumbling, decrepit, senile old bastard suffering
from the severest case of brain rot. Good job,
David. Y'all sure know how to pick em. Oh, and
don't think it's over. We're one year in wait till
China takes Taiwan. Y'all just need to shut the f
up forever. You have so much nerve to even still
be talking. You should never say another effing
word to us again with this joke of a first year
that's historically bad. LOL never again. Sit the
f down and be quiet. You've f enough s up already.
I can't wait until 2024. The red wave is going to
be breathtakingly glorious, and we both know it.
Thanks for sucking, but shut the f up from now on,
please. Y'all have been humiliated. Take the loss
and sit down. Thanks and then a bunch of clown
emojis. Very, very weaponise needs no response.
But this is just a reminder. One of the things
I like to talk about is there are people with
whom we can sit and talk and figure out political
differences. What is the role of the U.S. on the
world stage? Diplomatically, militarily, whatever?
What should the top tax rate be? How should
education be funded? There's people we can
disagree with but talk to. These are the types
of people where I believe they are essentially
a lost cause. In all practical terms, they
are a lost cause. Next e-mail is from Sophie.
Sophie says, Hey, David Biden has chosen his
words very carefully regarding the role of the
U.S. military in Putin's war on Russia, and so has
Jen Psaki. This has been the wording the U.S. will
not put military boots on the ground. Boots on the
ground is used over and over and over. There are
many types of military action the U.S. is capable
of outside of literal soldiers on the ground.
Yeah, this is a good point, and it's
something we've talked about before.
I believe that it is not an accidental choice
of words or a coincidental choice of words. They
are saying boots on the ground because probably
everything else is on the table, quite frankly.
And you know, people email me about drones. I
don't know that'd be a big step, but I think
that it is not an accident and they are. There's a
reason they are talking about boots on the ground
as the line because they want to leave open
the possibility of up to almost anything else
short of that, and we may soon see it. Chris
writes in about William Barr's interviews.
And here's Chris's view, Bar, in his interview,
is simply giving Trump cover to protect him from
criminal liability by opening the door for an
insanity plea. Should the prosecution ever make
enough headway besides that, how could you
describe such an obvious state of delusion
and then turn around and say he'd vote for such a
person? I think the answer to that is Barr's just
a horrible person. That alone should send a red
flag. As to his credibility, he betrays himself,
gangsters one and all. As with most of Trump's
loyal supporters, he's most likely being extorted.
Yeah, I don't. I just don't know about that.
I just I'm just not sure about that. We don't.
We don't have evidence of that. And it's not clear
to me that that that's what's going on. So I would
be careful about making those assessments. It's
conceivable Barr is trying to give Trump cover,
but you know, he's being blackmailed. Let's just
be sure we know what what we're saying and that
there's evidence behind it. I'm just not sure
about that. Mark wrote in with a correction. Sir,
you are mispronouncing nukes. Dear sir, I'm a big
fan of your show, but I recently noticed you have
a penchant for mispronouncing nukes as nukes. Case
in point, your recent video, titled Concerns Grow
that Putin will use nuclear weapons pronounced
properly. It should rhyme with Duke's not rebukes.
Duke's not rebukes. Do you OK? I know you're
a stickler for pronunciation, I want to make
you aware. Keep doing what doing what
you're doing, except for nukes. Yeah.
Nuclear. Nuclear. Nuclear nukes. Nukes. I hear the
difference. Nukes sounds more natural to me, and
I'm going to take that liberty. Given that English
is my second language, I think I'm sticking with
nukes. I've I've been this. People have written
to me before and they've said, David, you use
a liquid you when you pronounce the word new.
Some people say a new car new. I say a new car.
I think I'm going to stick with it, I like it.
Matthew writing in about our sponsor, Nabi Ashour.
This is pretty clever. Hey, David, I had
a question about your sponsor, Nebula.
Are these the types of showerheads where
the water comes out dripping very quietly?
Do you have to take a shower 10 to 15 times as
opposed to ones? I like the look into elements of
bathrooms very strongly before making a purchase.
Please let me know. Thank you. Yes, a very,
very important question. The Rabiah showerheads
are not. The water is not quietly dripping out.
It is it is lower water use, but it powerfully
comes out. You could bathe an elephant with it
if you needed to, if you could, if you could fit
the elephant in your bathtub. You could say that,
but I get the Trump references. Thank you, Jake
wrote in about the MMA fighter Bryce Mitchell,
who recently went on a delusional right wing
rant with right wing conspiracies about Ukraine.
Jake wrote It's notable that guys like that
MMA fighter have changed their thinking
so much since the U.S. invasion of Iraq. Back
then it was if we don't fight them over here,
we'll have to fight them. If we don't, sorry. Back
then it was if we don't fight them over there,
we'll have to fight them over here. Now, under a
Democratic president, they have no concern about
what's happening in other parts of the world,
even though it's obviously atrocious and it
could bring war over here. That's Johnny,
who I guess also goes by Jake. Yeah, this
it shouldn't surprise us that there is a stunning
level of hypocrisy from a lot of these people
now. I agree with not sending not putting boots
on the ground in Ukraine. Joe Biden has said that
from the beginning, he should stick to it. I think
it's the right thing, and I think he will stick to
that by the letter of what he said. But it
shouldn't be ignored that when the right
wants to justify military incursions, as they
did in Iraq in 2003 and have done elsewhere
and continued involvement in Afghanistan
for as long as that went on nearly 20 years,
they often say it's not that we want to be there.
But if we don't fight them, there will be fighting
them here. And many right wingers accept that,
and they say that's good, that's common sense,
that's logic. You're absolutely right. In this
particular case, they're not saying, they're
just saying now we shouldn't do it while, by the
way, at the same time saying Biden is being weak.
They would criticize Biden if he quote started a
war, as they love to say. And at the same time,
they say Biden is weak for not doing enough. The
point is these are bad faith actors. You can't
please them. And so we should pay enough attention
to know what they're saying. But I don't think we
need to take them very seriously. They're not good
faith actors. Next email today is about YouTube's
about Artie's YouTube channel Artie
being Russian state media propaganda.
Hi David, today I love this. The the the
delightful naivete of this email. Hey,
David, today I found a Russian
backed YouTube channel called Artie.
All of the videos are pro-Russia and anti-West.
If you read the comments on the videos,
they are all pro-Russia as well. Many of the
misleading videos on this channel are disgusting.
I just wanted to get your opinion on if you think
YouTube should shut it down and join the other
hundreds of companies that have already pulled
out of Russia. Yeah. So first of all, I I envy
someone who has not been suffering through knowing
that art exists and the content that they produce
for the last decade. Now, as many of you know,
I used to appear as a guest on our team when
invited, thinking I'll go wherever and give
my views. But once it became clear to me that,
like barely anyone was watching this stuff in the
U.S. and it's not even worth my time to appear,
nor do I want to be associated with it in any way.
I just started turning down all of my all invites,
and I've probably turned down, I don't know,
eight invitations there over the last few years.
I would love instead to just not even be
aware that there was this propaganda thing
being disseminated in the U.S.. Now
that being said, for the person emailing
YouTube demonetized the art channel and marked
it as Russian state media and art America ceased
operations. So it's over for now, at least.
And that's a good thing. That's a good thing.
Last email today is from Julia about the
term strongman. Julius says, Hey, David,
please stop referring to Machiavellian Mad Men
as strong men, it's a misleading connotation when
what they actually are is cowardly, psychopathic
bullies who con and rely on their minions
to brutalize and oppress others for their own
narcissistic gain. That term gives people away
to positive idea about them and allows the weak
minded a rationale to follow them. Yeah, that's
probably true. I mean, sometimes I'll refer to a
dictatorial authoritarians. I think the problem is
sometimes they're not literally dictators. So
to just call them dictators isn't accurate,
which is why I often say authoritarian strongmen.
But it would be good to have a different term,
maybe dictatorial authoritarians or wannabe
dictators instead of strongmen. I'm open to that.
I'm open to that. But a good point, Julie. I
appreciate you emailing in about that. If you
have a topic for discussion for the mailbag, you
can email info at David Pakman dot com. Please
don't abuse the email address. In all seriousness,
we get a lot of crap in there, but you can email
info at David Pakman dot com. We have a great
bonus show coming up for you today. You get
access to the bonus show by becoming a member
Unidentified: at Join Hackman dot com.